[Music]
all right
it's true
Friday everybody it's Friday
and you know what that means when it's
Friday it's time to welcome tonight's
guests our forecast is so on the money
people mistake her for Susan B Anthony
Fox news the news senior meteorologist
and author of the new book I am the
storm Janice Dean
when he produces a TV show characters
ask to be killed off founder of the
loftusparty.com Michael Lofton
and rattlesnakes describe her as two
poisonous Fox News contributor ketchup
and finally elephants won't discuss him
when he's in the room
my massive sidekick in the NWA World
Heavyweight Champion Tyres
e okay before we get to some news
stories obviously since it's Friday it's
time for this
Briggs leftovers
hmm yeah I love leftovers this is where
I read the jokes we didn't use this week
and as always it'll be my first time
reading these so if they suck it's not
my fault and you say the word and I'll
fire the staff
here we go
this week President Biden addressed the
classified documents found in his garage
when asked why he thought a garage would
be a safe place for such things he said
because Hunter has been hiding his Coke
stash there for 15 years
and he's never lost an ounce fair enough
speaking
speaking of Hunter he's asking a judge
to deny his four-year-old daughter that
he had with a former stripper from
taking his last name because if there's
one thing Hunter won't tolerate it's
someone using the Biden name for
unearned gain
what's the difference
TSA officers seized an anti-tank tank
weapon from a passenger's luggage at a
Texas Airport this week in his defense
the passenger said he wanted to have the
advantage when it came to fighting over
the armrest
there's only so many jokes he can make
that's bad
tweak this
there's an unveiled a metal sculpture
honoring Martin Luther King Jr but
critics say that it actually resembles a
giant penis
that doesn't look like kill Mead
[Laughter]
a punch line
looks like a giant penis although that
just proves whatever dream Dr King had
must have been a good one
and the good news is when it's cold out
the sculpture shrinks to half its size
[Applause]
North Dakota lawmakers are weighing a
ban on sexually explicit books found in
libraries in response Librarians have
asked if officials could also ban books
on suicide since no one ever brings them
back
what what
that was good I thought that was going
somewhere else it took a turn at the end
that's you know that's called surprise
Loftus try that with your wardrobe
oh I see it's I see it's your day at the
shelter to wear the denim jacket
I'm a freezer the good thing is though
he does have the teeth so you can make
the trade later that is true all right I
get teeth
two NYPD officers were reportedly caught
having sex in a Precinct parking lot
after the woman's moans prompted a 9-1-1
call the dispatcher told the concern
caller not to worry that the police were
definitely coming
huh all right it's good
during a live taping of the view a
Heckler called Whoopi Goldberg an old
broad the Rowdy audience member was
immediately removed and given an award
for accuracy in the media
in a partnership with Duncan Hines
country Legend Dolly Parton has created
a new line of baking mixes including
Buttermilk Biscuits the only downside
you can only bake two at a time
oh I get it
there's you yeah that's right Michael uh
thanks for explaining the joke to
America
I'm here to help yes in a recent
interview 76 year old Suzanne Summers
says she has sex with her 84 year old
husband about three times a day and
according to her husband most of the
time he's awake
yeah
and finally in protest over Roe v Wade
liberal American men are reportedly
getting a record high number of
vasectomies the good news for them is
that doctors are willing to charge half
price since they already have no balls
I don't know if that's how science works
but let's do some news right well he
left classified docs where his son
smoked rocks
that's a good one yesterday President
Biden toured storm-battered California
neighborhoods where winds were so strong
Gavin newsom's hair was declared a
disaster Zone and this time the watery
brown stuff on everyone's shoes in San
Francisco was mud
that's poop Janice yeah talking about
diarrhea
and if Joe's barely coherent comments a
reporter shouted out a question about
classified dots and Joe Biden was mad
about the timing just like when I fired
that intern after he gave me his kidney
you know what quite frankly that bugs me
you know what quite frankly bugs me is
that we have serious problem here we're
talking about
we're talking about what's going on and
the American people don't quite
understand why you don't ask me
questions about that
[Music]
um
he's supposed to count to four and a
half when he's angry
I missed halfs
I stopped using halves after we turned
13.
I want to go back to halves but I think
you're gonna find there's nothing here
I think you're gonna find there's
nothing there I have no regrets I'm
following what the lawyers have told me
they want me to do it's exactly what
we're doing there's no there there no
there there sounds like a good
description of Joe's pulse
unless there means Hunter and turns out
he was voracious readers pointed out
that Hunter Biden described in his
Memoir being quarantined for days inside
Pop's Wilmington Mansion the same spot
where the classified docks were lying
around in the garage his lawyers already
hid incriminating documents where no one
will ever look inside a copy of how I
saved the World by Jesse Waters
Hunter apparently had unrestricted
access to the property and the Corvette
he prefers the top down on his car but
also his brother's wife
damn
it was damn
that joke was actually worse I cleaned
it up
I know what say you Joe
oh no no look look
there's no there there
I said that before there's no there
there
is no why why
and nowhere for wherefore
come on man there's no they they
there's no wee-wee
wow that's wow there's a little wee-wee
dude tells me that's normal for someone
of my age
all right
so I do this from time to time Janice I
have Janice a great new book I am the
storm uh when does it come out it's out
where is it do you know you won't know
to where our ranks till next Tuesday
it's a bestseller already fantastic I
just thought I always thought about you
all right enough what I like to do
whenever uh somebody has a book I like
to read a little bit so can I read a
paragraph from it I would be honest all
right so the first time I met Greg
Gutfeld I was blown away by how good
looking he was in person
I had to control myself because my
husband was around
but I found myself in a deep longing
desire to throw myself at him but then
he looked at me and he said Greg
I should stop nobody died actually when
whenever he gets a book you know what's
the first thing he does he goes to the
index and looks for his own name I've
noticed I noticed that yeah that's okay
yeah it is anyway uh no no go back to
that page keep reading yeah
it's actually more interesting he was
wearing nothing but Lycra in his quads
glistened in the Sun
[Music]
liberal media didn't tell you about that
liberal media didn't tell you about his
abs or his traps
should I keep going yes I better not
damn that liberal media never talking
about my quads Janice uh using nothing
but weather terminology how would you
categorize this document Scandal Ms Dean
category five oh yeah but you know what
I love is seeing Gavin Newsom in the
background going oh I would look really
good at that Podium oh can he faint
right now right because you know he
wants to be president yeah no this is
all that's the irony here Loftus it's
the same people that got him into the
office are exactly the same people that
are trying to get him out it's all the
Democrat machine he served his purpose
he was the uh what do you call that uh
thing placeholder idiot yes placeholder
idiots
Scandal because when Biden's like I had
no idea I agree I bet you don't yeah
yeah everybody the Corvette it's weird
who I feel sorry for in the I feel sorry
for whoever was quarantined with Hunter
Biden that's a nightmare scenario right
there we know it wasn't a real
quarantine like his definition of
quarantine is half the crack right you
know but it's just
four Horrors instead of eight
and you got a ration you got a ration
yes exactly they were the best of times
they were the worst of them yes I was
down to my fourth Russian hooker and
only a few crumbled bits of Parmesan
cheese but somehow we got through yes
it's horrible it is that it brings me to
my I think this is the most important
question cat
letting Hunter have access to a place
holding classified documents while he's
doing deals with our enemies as well as
meth and crack this is insane it's like
like nobody has actually connected all
of that together him plus documents
garage drugs China all in one spot yeah
especially when you see Biden being so
flippant about the whole thing yeah yeah
he's like no regrets yeah who are you
like a 20 year old girl in Cabo who
throws up at the beach club after having
too many pina coladas like that's that's
what people like that say in those
situations not when you're undergoing
this kind of serious thing we all you
know hear absolute power corrupts
absolutely but people don't realize it's
a scale the more power you have the more
likely it will be that you'll have
corruption and he knows that he's a
powerful person nothing's probably gonna
happen like is so often the case with
powerful people so he's just like yeah
whatever no regrets YOLO whatever is not
even a little Cabo ain't ready for us
I'm sure they are yeah you're a major
pillar of their economy I think he's he
gets more upset when they're out of
pistachio yeah
well that because that actually affects
him yeah it does directly yeah yes okay
first of all you're not gonna besmirch
my favorite ice cream pistachios I love
pistachios yeah he's a mint chocolate
chip guy okay okay not the green kind
the white kind that no one wants to eat
oh you're right about that yeah you just
gotta have dye in it why are you against
white ice cream
because it's everywhere
well Greg I hate to disagree with you
but they didn't get him in he got them
in and that's why they put up with this
because they Bernie didn't have enough
right and Kamala was well you saw it
yeah so he's in there but
I know we don't have time to go back to
the speech but he forgot he got
frustrated he goes what bugs me is we're
here talking about
something important yes they forgot what
and you know what that is
it's important
and there's and Cat I believe you're
correct it was a 20 year old that wrote
that speech because he was like no
regrets
there's no there there coming from a guy
who forgets everything he literally
forgot he was President yeah
so yeah but yeah the one last thing was
the documents are six years old they're
there after they're already used Hunter
hit them like he hit the laptop and the
pistol and the child sloppily yeah
they've already been used they've
already been paid for that's why they
can turn them over now you know he
should just say when he said there was
no there there that he was just
stuttering
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else